seither schon hallo herzlich willkommen
in unserem zuhause und heute startet die
tour ich zeige euch mal das wohn und
esszimmer küche ein erster aus der mitte
[Musik]
das ist fast egal ob ein
hier ist unser eingangsbereich und zwar
ganz wichtig dass man sich wirklich wohl
und willkommen fühlt wenn man bei uns
ist weise sind ziemlich großer raum
aber bei uns bisher immer so in der
alten wohnung und auch in der davor
warte eingang immer relativ schmal immer
ganz klein und man musste wirklich sich
immer durch drücken um in die wohnung zu
kommen
deswegen haben wir hier einen großen
raum ursprünglich war geplant dass hier
hinter mir ein großer einbauschrank
entsteht aber dann waren wir beim xxx
unter murat hat sich in dieses sofa hier
verlebt deswegen haben dieses sofa hier
reingestellt und dann alles andere
drumherum gebaut was sie am eingang
ziemlich schnell auffällt ist der
fußboden was aussieht wie ein großer
teppich sind in wirklichkeit
zementplatten die sind alle handmade
kommen aus bacharach und die haben wir
gefunden über unsere freundin almut die
macht sie nämlich und essen sowie er
platten erinnern so ein bisschen an
spanien da gibt es ja auch diese
handgemachten platten und fließen das
hier sind sie mit mosaik platten und die
haben wir den kompletten raum damit
gefüllt das war auch das erste was wir
hier gemacht haben zuerst im fußboden
ausgesucht dann haben wir die wände
gestaltet hier oben noch den stock der
wirklich super dazu passt dann kam von
murat die idee mit dem sofa und jetzt
habe ich praktisch drumherum einfach
noch die kleiderschränke gebaut also
hier links und rechts haben wir jeweils
den großen kleiderschrank
da passen unsere jacken reihen unserer
schuhe aber eben auch die schuhe und
jacken von den gästen was mir besonders
wichtig war
hier ist zum beispiel der kleiderschrank
mit meinen sachen also meine jacken und
meine schuhe die ich so momentan trage
der rest ich oben und ich habe ich dann
einfach noch so eine stange daran
gemacht für handtaschen also so für die
zwei die ich für jeden tag habt so hat
nämlich auch die handtasche endlich
einen platz und steht nicht irgendwo in
der ecke herum hier neben der
eingangstür haben wir auch direkt unsere
stahl holztreppe die haben wir selber
gemacht um alex zusammen
und dann habe ich mir gedacht nutzen war
einfach den platz unter der treppe und
machen einfach nur ein kleiderschrank
hin für die kinder hier können samira
und eltern nämlich ihre sachen schön
verstauen und vor allem ihr kennt das
problem
die kinder können jetzt ihre jacken und
schuhe selber aufräumen
vorher war es nämlich immer so mama hier
meine jacke hier meine schuhe räumt mal
weg weil einfach die garderobenstange
doch zu hoch war jetzt können sie selber
aufhängen und ich habe die arbeit nicht
mehr mit dem hinterher räumen und dann
kommt man von hier aus direkt in die
wohnung
bei uns ist der mittelpunkt des hauses
natürlich die küche deswegen sieht man
die hier wirklich zuallererst zur küche
kommen wir aber ein anderes mal da mache
ich ein gesondertes video und direkt an
die küche angeschlossen ist der wohn
essbereich da fühlen wir uns am wohlsten
wir haben auch extra eine offene küche
gewählt damit wir wirklich alles hier
integrieren können weil ich einfach den
ganzen tag in der küche stellt die
kinder helfen mir morath macht im at
von daher passt alles wirklich gut
zusammen wir haben unseren wohn
essbereich der ich auch relativ
großzügig mit blick direkt raus auf die
terrasse und ich zeige mich jetzt hier
einfach mal so die einzelnen sachen
vielleicht könnte da die eine oder
andere abschauen
[Musik]
schuster grad mit hochdruck die terrasse
wisst ihr ich will hier gerade
moderieren aber murat putz der terrasse
nico geht's erstmal zu murat was da
gemacht
ach das ist doch ein vorbildlicher immer
der post jeden tag der terrasse
normalerweise macht man ja wenn man ein
haus plant am besten einen raum zur
raumplanung das heißt wir beim
architekten selbst das haus plant und
die räume so durchgeht weiß man im
prinzip schon wo steht das sofa wo soll
mal der esstisch stehen und bei uns war
es aber so wir haben das haus geplanten
in graz bruder des bauzeichner und ich
habe mir natürlich überlegt wo soll was
stehen aber so ganz hatten wir noch
keinen raumkonzept wir haben dann gesagt
kommen wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an
und so war es dann auch mal ein bisschen
blöd denn am ende sind die kosten
natürlich etwas höher
am anfang kann man nämlich sagen ich
plane das alles weiß ganz genau was auf
mich zukommt und bin eben nicht so ganz
spontan und flexibel
wir haben es aber dann doch für spontan
und flexibel entschieden weil wir auch
noch nicht wussten welchen stil wollen
wir wollen war so ein bisschen feiner
wohl wahr denn fabrik stil wollen wir
keine ahnung shabby chic gibt es glaube
ich auch noch deswegen war wieder
relativ offen was wir bei am anfang
direkt schon wussten das haben wir nicht
bei unseren freunden arbeit gesehen war
der sichtbeton estrich und zwar ist es
ein richtig schöner wunderschöner
bodenbelag den haben wir hier aber auch
vor dem der küche und im prinzip ist der
gar nicht so teuer wie viel auch immer
denken
normalerweise braucht man ja einen ganz
normalen estrich und daneben den
fußbodenbelag im estrich kostete im
schnitt etwa 35 euro
und je nachdem was für einen
fußbodenbelag man dann nimmt egal ob
fliesen parkett laminat teppichboden
oder was auch immer ist man schnell mal
bei 100 euro oder mehr
und wir haben hier in den bereichen
einfach den sichtbeton estrich genommen
und beim sichtbeton spricht da waren wir
deutlich unter 100 euro das macht aber
auch nicht jeder bei uns hat jetzt der
band gemacht und zwar die firma mortimer
das macht auch nicht jeder weil man beim
arbeiten wirklich sehr sauber und
präzise arbeiten muss wohl das garantie
gründen macht wirklich nicht jede firma
steht bei uns im erdgeschoss hat
wirklich super gepasst ich liebe den
fußboden weil er total einfach ist in
der reinigung er ist ganz pflegeleicht
und ich bin aber auch so ein mensch ich
sehe keinen den dreck und mache ihn weg
hier sieht man ihn nicht unbedingt aber
man kann eben auch wenn der ganz
weg machen zum teppich kommen wir später
jetzt zeige ich erstmal noch dem möge
das erste was wir für das wohnzimmer
ausgesucht haben ist das sofa das sofa
ist finde ich so ein ganz wichtiges
möbelstück denn darf verbringt man auch
relativ viel zeit drauf es muss bequem
sein es müssen alle drauf passen
es muss aber auch schön und stylisch
sein und wir haben uns jetzt hier für
dieses sofa entschieden und bei uns sage
jetzt auch wirklich viele wow ihr habt
echt viele farben bei euch im wohnzimmer
und das ist echt sehr mutig es gibt
wirklich verschiedene arten von menschen
es gibt die menschen die sagen ich kauf
mir alle drei bis vier jahre neue möbel
kauft deswegen günstig ein und schmeiße
dann noch drei fähren weg und es gibt
die die sagen ich lege wert auf qualität
hole mir meine möbel stück einmal und
habe wirklich ganz lange was davon
wir sind so von der sorte letzteres also
wir wollen einmal möbelstück hohl und
wirklich viele jahre was davon haben
daher muss auch die qualität stimmen und
wir haben zwar farbe gewählt aber ich
muss auch sagen wir sind sehr mutig wir
leben jetzt schon seit zehn jahren
zusammen oder nicht und wir hatten
unsere erste wohnung die war relativ
schlicht und braun gehalten die zweite
wohnung war es erweist und irgendwann
habe ich es akkurat mut zur farbe denn
ich liebe farben ich liebe das bunte
das ist bei mir weh wenn ich so eine
bunte blumenwiese seht da geht es mir
auf einen schlag viel besser weil farben
mich einfach mich persönlich zeit
glücklich machen
deswegen haben wir auch hier die
wandfarbe so gewählt in petrol und
petrol und senf oder patronen kurkuma
sind einfach so haben die ich sehr liebe
eine richtig tolle kombi deswegen hat
mir auch die ehre des netzes hat diesen
adventskranz gemacht gegen meine
lieblingsfarben und bei mir ist es nicht
ein adventskranz das ist einfach ein
jahres kranz denn da steht bei mir jetzt
schon fast ein halbes jahr
und der steht auch hier weil er einfach
schön und dazu passt dieses sofa hier
ist von musterring das haben wir auch
bei xxxlutz ausgesucht da gibt es ja
wirklich eine riesenauswahl man kann
hinfahren alle möbel einmal ausprobieren
drauflegen drauf sitzen die beine
ausstrecken meine lieblings halte offen
sich übrigens hier
da lege ich hier und uns war wichtig
dass milch platz haben das aber auch die
kinder platz haben wie sie jetzt nicht
so die fernsehgucker aber irgendwann am
abend muss doch eine serie sein beim xxx
lutz hat man den vorteil dass
darum möbel gibt für alle preisklassen
wermuth so in der mittleren schiene
bewegt haben wirklich darauf geachtet
auf gute qualität regionaler hersteller
und auf spanischen aussehen und wie nett
zusammen zum xxx lutz und schauen uns
doch die möbel an
[Musik]
das ist aber nicht fürs wohnzimmer
aber ich finde es jetzt cool wenn es
jetzt im ding wäre im eingang mit
eingang ist groß und ich bin mir meiner
sofa steht da kommst du rein und es ist
das so anziehen oder ist er zum
schweizer wollen wir es jetzt möglich
keit und an sie zeitgleich außerhalb
kommen schreien oder say komm setz dich
hin fühl dich wohl auch schon groß
ja ich denke schon und dann ist das
sagen leute gucken
das war dann irgendwie recht noch einen
schrank oder so oder wie oft nicht schon
im eingang auf dich wartet bist du
fertig bist ich habe mich schon klingt
doch gar noch ich waren immer auf die
haben bestimmt schon ohne mich schon
drei jahre drei jahre meines lebens in
eingang verbracht weil ich sagt schatz
mit gegen die gegen die gehen aber wisst
ihr warum weil der murat er macht sich
immer einfach da sagt dann immer wir
gehen jetzt und er zählt einfach nur
seine jacke an und seine schuhe und
fertig ich ziehe mich an die kinder
jetzt auch einfach mal nicht nur den tee
aus machen ich könnte hier auch einfach
nur flaggen im mond im eingang macht
stand nicht gleich in die kissen gibt
sie dann dazu cool und den schluss kommt
suchen auch nicht schön
[Musik]
und das ist es 100 prozent garantieren
das ideale sein papa die hocken hat
gerade und das ist dann so die sitzen
halt gerne wenn meine eltern sitzen
so führt uns jetzt mal aufrecht gerade
kann es gerade sagen du bist gerade 1
mir sofort das ist mein sofa kam ich mit
bruce und karomuster hab ich noch gar
nicht halt es gibt verschiedene
geschmäcker aber kannst mir gefallen tun
wenn wenn das so war jemand kauft kann
ich mich anrufen um mich um mich um mich
mit der person verbinden wenn ich mal
gerne mitreden
ich meine bequem ist es ja aber
tatsächlich so richtig bequem und jetzt
wie in so einer partie steht haben wir
so jetzt bin ich aus dem flugzeug muss
ich sagt als ich in meinem leben noch
nie business geflogen
ja aber ich hab mir menschen was macht
so das ist jetzt so ein richtig cooles
meiner meinung nach männer sofa also so
richtig leder und ich zeige jetzt mal
was darf ich das mal zeigen kannst du es
ja ein paar kratzer rein gemacht aber
jetzt machst du so
und dann ist dieser weg und es ist so
finde ich ein typisches männer sofa und
es hat auch eine funktion
also wenn ich was wenn ich bestimmen
könnte dann wäre das definitiv alle
verrückten richtig auch das anhört ist
von tonia um hörst du das hört sich an
als würde ich ein krachen lassen und
macht sauber machen aber nicht
ich verspreche den lask einen drachen
nicht richtig cool wirklich gefällt mir
ein richtig cooles männer sofa ist das
kuschel sofa hallo ich deine arme
aufmachen so kuschel
[Musik]
also ich bin beim möbelkauf man erkennt
uns ja ich wäre gern darauf achten dass
wir auch regionale sachen kaufen ich
mein es schaut so alles hat seinen preis
und jeder möchte fair verdienen aber
jeder muss auch bezahlen
man kann nicht sagen man möchte ein
faires gehalt bekommen kauft aber dann
nur importierte machten es geht und wer
verdienen will muss eben auch mehr
bezahlen und deswegen achten wir über
höhere gekauft drauf dass sie eben auch
regionale hersteller haben das heißt für
mich also es kommt nicht überall in dem
nicht überall wenn man kauft auch müll
bestimmt weil sein passen muss einmal
aufgenommen wir kommen jetzt eben auch
nach marken und herstellern die eben aus
der region sind deutschland österreich
schweiz rolf benz musterring hat das
clever sein und zwar ich habe früher
druckerei gearbeitet im oberlauf am
neckar beim fotodruck darf ich die
werbung machen ja und wir haben immer
die visitenkarten für sprints gemacht
und ja und vollständig kennst du dir ja
und rolf benz ist aus nagold und ich
habe schon eine zuschauerin so jemand
schafft bayreuth bands in nagold also
darauf komme auch achten oder zum
beispiel team 77 ist österreich das ist
so eine manufaktur die möbel sind im
ersten sie etwas teurer aber nicht fair
hergestellt es gibt ja auch verschiedene
käuferschichten der eine sagt hecht
kaufen jetzt ein möbelstück extra ganz
günstig damit ich in drei jahren wieder
neues holen kann und der andere sagt ich
lege wert auf qualität und
nachhaltigkeit wie zum beispiel wir
wollen nicht so viel müll auf der welt
produzieren
deswegen werden auch unser altes sofa
nicht weggeschmissen sondern wir haben
es einfach in der alten wohnung gelassen
für unseren freund wolke also die möbel
wurden alle weiter geschenkt und werden
jetzt auch weiter benutzt sich auch in
super hochwertiges sofa also das hat uns
alles viele jahre viel freude bereitet
und wir gehören eigentlich auch erzeuger
schlecht wir wollen sind einmal kaufen
und dann einfach für die nächsten jahre
da gibt es zum beispiel höchster hilft
das auch cool weil höchster sagt
tropenhölzer gehören truppen in dem raum
schnell sagt die coole geschichte
und dann muss man mich darauf achten in
welcher lebenssituation ist man hat man
etwas mehr geld achten auf qualität wenn
man es machen kann dann sollte man es
auch machen wirklich jasmin sprechen
gerade mal sowas großen sofa
rolf benz war schon immer ein fan davon
muss ich sagen aber ich glaube wir haben
da hinten was gesehen was schon ein
bisschen mehr an sagt demonstriert er
okay das finde ich cool weil wenn wir
auch im fernseher klar im wohnzimmer ich
meine demokratischer so nahe stehen
morgens auf das erste was morath macht
nach dem zähneputzen anziehen fernseher
an nachrichten gucken und ich bin eher
so ich will bis zum abend eigentlich
kein fernseher sehen
deswegen denke ich denn dann lieber hat
die farbe vom glas ändern du kannst die
farben noch mal ändern
es kann nicht jemanden zeigen haben das
auch von höchster das wäre von höchster
genau ist ein deutscher hersteller
ok die sind eigentlich sehr flexibel man
kann es sogar deckenhoch bekommen
wirklich perfekt an die wand anpassen an
die decke naja hohe räume vielleicht
richtig müssen wir überlegen ob es dann
zu viel wird oder ob man vielleicht doch
auf der höhe bleiben das wirkt ein
bisschen luftiger
[Musik]
dieses sofa ist für die türkische
großfamilien dem rat wenn du das vendome
des kaufs dann kam ich gerne mal zwei
kinder haben dann passen wir alle drauf
ich verstehe zwar dass zwischending
zwischen den künsten raus man ist ein
bisschen kleiner
also wenn du den platz hast wirklich der
hast du da haben wir wirklich richtig
schön
doch bei uns jetzt fast zu eng ja und
der stoff wer bei uns auch zu schade
manchmal ja ich abwaschen doch schon
aber ich finde einfach dass ich das wäre
echt zu schade ist aber jetzt mehr schon
samt in im eingang aber wunderschön
möglich auch sehr bequem
das ist heißt schönste was ich heute
hier gesehen haben also das ist halt die
funktion der stoff ist cool tag mal
gucken was ist immer cool und deshalb
das lederne eigentlich wollte ich ja nie
in leder so war denn im sommer es ist
alltag lebt man dann so drauf mit kurzen
hosen im winter ist so kalt aber das
fühlt sich ja gar nicht so kalt an
also wie gibt zeigen die unterschiede
das kommt bisschen auf die wertigkeit
von dem laserdrucker oki es heißen so
hochwertig dass unser atmungsaktiv weil
es ist auch da ist zwar farbe braucht
aber es ist schon auf dem bericht
dadurch wirkt das auch relativ warm im
winter ist es nicht so kalt und im
sommer ist es nicht also ich finde es
ist auch ein weiches leben gefällt ist
auch ein mittel die mit kindern
mir gefällt die farbe auch hammermäßig
liebe die farbe es ist kein
naturbelassenes
ein ganz gut ab waschen putzen
ermöglicht drauf ja komm sag ich mal ist
auf jeden fall pflegeleichter 1,42 wir
sind zwar nicht gerade die schlanksten
wichtig mir leid aber bald voll cool
oder
ja und ich würde schon dieses senfgelb
bockumer nehmen weil wenn wir die wand
petrol tapeziert und ich glaube es ist
echt gut dann noch bisschen olivgrünen
dazu bisschen respekt weil es ein
bisschen so erdige töne
ja ich würde mich sperriges reinnehmen
das finde ich so kraft versuchen so
ertönen
da sieht man sich auch nicht satt das
kann man das auch konfigurieren
ihr habt so klein groß mittel ohne 11
das möchtest kannst hier nochmal
konfigurieren ich zeig dir mal nachholen
oder euch ob es größer sein sollen
kleider sein soll vollkommen ich mir
halt nichts wenn nicht ganz da kannst du
dann auch billiger und teurer machen
geht es dann auch mit dem alter das ist
auch das coole ist ich sehe jetzt gerade
das ist ein super von musterring recht
das ist made in germany in die coole
geschichte also mir gefällt auf jeden
fall mehr habe her und und es richtig
schillig und mal das kann man jetzt auch
und kam auch zum modus machen ich sage
immer das ist dass wir jetzt den besuch
modus gestehe es so da und kann mit den
menschen ziemlich normal unterhalten und
jetzt machen wir mal kurz netflix modus
fußball modus ich habe meine ecke genau
fußball modus coop modus und da können
wir dann mit kiffen drauf dekorieren
handball modus schlammcatchen nein das
nicht
das stimmt ja nicht gefällt mir immer 5
ok
[Musik]
der service sind bei uns ziemlich
wichtig auch bei der auswahl hat uns
echt schwer
die stühle müssen bequem seine tisch
muss lang genug sein vor allem bei uns
spielt es ist immer eine große rolle
denn wir essen gerne und wenn mir
freunde da haben oder wissen wissen
immer am esstisch
und weil man noch mal machen zum
beispiel war es immer so die hatten zwei
meter tief und wenn dann besucht haben
müssen wir dann immer ausziehen dann aus
jedem raum irgendwo war immer ein stuhl
noch mal alles so zusammen gewürfelt und
ich jetzt gern so ich meine wir haben
wir die länge bei uns im esszimmer und
ich hätte einfach kein einen großen
langen esstisch wo mindestens jeder sohn
zehn bis zwölf dran passen immer wo
immer die stühle daran haben nicht
ausbauen müssen nichts zusammenklappen
wir essen also nicht das willst dann
dauernd nur am essen sind mir aber warum
dann bewusst so genau und er ist noch
lange oder mit freunden zusammen um für
uns sein das schönste ist wenn die
coolsten partys in der küche statt und
nach der küche dann es jetzt können dann
meine eltern immer zu uns runterkommt
schön lang und vor allem finde ich cool
natürlich ist also wir sind vier plus
meine eltern und meine schwester mein
bruder also genau da kommt vielleicht
nur die nation mit ihrem mann auf jeden
fall
habt ihr auch tisch hat die jetzt über
drei meter ohne ausbau genau da können
wir uns regional erstmal vorbei 77 jetzt
das ist jetzt klar das ist etwas es hört
sich blöd und gesagt hochpreisiger wenn
es ist eine manufaktur ist weiß ich aus
wien team siegen man so coole sachen
muss ich ehrlich sagen willst da kommt
ja auch bei uns aus deutschland ich bin
das damit man es einfach gucken was
besser gepasst er wird glaube ich jetzt
ein bisschen moderner aussehen und vor
allem lang ganz wichtig ganz
langzeitstudie müssen ganz bequem ja die
stühle bequem und dann vielleicht noch
ein bisschen dunkleren ton nicht schwarz
aber wir kommen war es auch richtig
schön
[Musik]
stühle gibt es in hülle und fülle und
viele verschiedene formen
ich mag zum beispiel ganz gerne stühle
die einfach vier beine haben deswegen
glaube ich schon entscheiden wir uns für
diesen hier so schwingt stühle sind zwar
eigentlich ganz bequem man kann auch
immer so ein bisschen wippen und ja
nicht so ganz startet schon fest aber
ich weiß auch nicht auch zum
saubermachen
ich finde einfach ich bin so der
klassische typ der stuhl mit vier beinen
und ich mag es auch ganz gerne wenn er
so ein bisschen hier um die kurve geht
wissen auch bequem kann man da auch den
bezug anders machen
nicht sparen also es gab so schwarzwild
bei uns ist die wand pedro ja genau
selbst gelb und das ist ding als auch in
altenbauna thron
ich würde so in die dunkelblauen
dunkelgrünen ja gerne wer sich jetzt
netz nehmen weil es danach im sofa was
grün ist nicht cool oder wir könnten
auch grau grau wird aufpassen aber ich
finde nein goalies könnte wiederholt
kritisch so natürlich holz richtig cool
und vor allem die chrome füßen nicht gut
weil hier wächst dann chrom und
irgendwie holz miteinander ein
und vielleicht ein großes talent er ist
jetzt insgesamt 220 haben wir zu klein
weil ja mal du kannst ja er ist 2 meter
20 schon 67 usa bekommen es wirklich
also 80 km/h um vier plätze erweitert
genauso auf drei meter ziehen würde
schon bekommen hat passen würden
es kommt nur eine fußballmannschaft
komplett oder wenn wir es uns unser team
der tar marius der marcel frank bringen
ich glaube ich gerne schön schöner
warmer ton
ja richtig schön dass der körper durch
seine an der boden warnt auch die das
muss bauen
ich kann man bei der bahn waren die aus
nussbaum nehmen da passt der völlig zu
dem raschen ausbau coolness gut und da
bräuchten wir jetzt halt auch eine
leuchte die jetzt irgendwie noch über
den ganzen tisch ja richtig coole
geschichte beleuchten ein echtes leben
cool red dot award winner
ja also habe das auch
[Musik]
der bühne würde jetzt sagen ich sehe aus
wie ein typischer teppichverkäufer aber
heftig ist sowas genial es wirklich das
ist wirklich kommt euch mal das ding an
wahnsinn oder was noch viel cooler ist
gleichzeitig man teppich der ist richtig
gehen ja und zwar gerade da hier vorne
[Musik]
das problem ist wenn das haus noch gar
nicht dekoriert ist dann passt ja alles
dann fast jedes team bekommt man alles
kaufen blumen auf den tischen aber schön
und schnittblumen mag ich nicht so ganz
gerne weil frische schnittblumen die hat
man dann für ein paar tage und dann sind
sie wieder kaputt und ich finde
mittlerweile gibt es echt richtig tolle
kunstblumen und da kann man sich so ein
gesteck machen für auf den esstisch zum
beispiel oder für ein wohnzimmertisch
und da hat man immer schön
[Musik]
eine stimme hat wird seine mutter gut
gefallen kann man dem buch streich noch
einmal an seinen spaß
[Musik]
ich werde voll der kisten und körbe
mensch und muss halt immer aufpassen
dass man nicht so viele davon nimmt aber
so gezielt eingesetzt bin ich schon ganz
praktisch man kann sachen verstauen wie
kleinteile zum beispiel und dann sieht
es immer gleich richtig ordentlich und
trotzdem dekorativ aus
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir unser sofa schon seit
etwa fünf sechs monaten jeden tag in
gebraucht und ich bin echt mega
zufrieden die farbe gefällt mir vor
allem die pflege werden in unserer alten
wohnung auch in viletta sofa auch vom
xxx lutz damit war ich auch sehr
zufrieden da hatten wir eben nur das
problem dass die ela einfach doch immer
wieder mal was verschüttet auf dem sofa
und irgendwann hast du flecken du
kriegst es zwar sauber auch das wild
ledersofa wurde immer sauber aber man
musste es eben immer nass reinigen jetzt
haben wir hier diesen tollen lederbezug
und da ist echt super ich kann einfach
abwischen murat hatte hier sogar mal
kugelschreiber flecken weg gemacht als
echt mega das einzige was ich ändern
würde ist die größe des sofas so sieht
zwar relativ groß aus aber wir sind ja
schon zu viert meine eltern sind ständig
hier ganz immer zu sechst und wenn wir
dann noch freunde zu gast haben wird es
so war echt eng
ich meine ich sitze auch gerne mal auf
dem boden vor allem auf dem teppich
haben wir noch diesen sessel mit
dazugenommen das passt aber ich glaube
so eine so ver einheit mehr hätte hier
echt gut getan und dann hätten alle
wirklich ganz ganz viel platz
ich finde hier mehr so der buch leser
oder auch mal der serien gucken bei
murat ist aber das erste wasser macht
wenn er morgens aufsteht er kommt
herunter natürlich nach dem zähneputzen
und anziehen und schaltet den fernseher
ein
denn er will nicht verpassen was auf der
welt los ist also werden zuerst einmal
die nachrichten geguckt da bin ich ja
echt mega allergisch aus dem nachrichten
gucke ich gar nicht so gerne weil ich
immer sagt dann kannst du es ähnlich und
da kommt eh nur schlecht ist dann hast
du schlechte laune
jedenfalls hat gesagt der fernseher muss
da drüben direkt gegenüber von der couch
hin und ich wollte einfach nicht dass
man den fernseher ständig sieht und
deswegen haben wir uns dann für diese
wohnwand entschieden
da hat der fernseher schönen platz wir
müssen den nur in der höhe noch ein
bisschen vorstellen dass er mittig sitzt
und das außenrum kam dann einfach so
dazu weil wir das auch eben im
ladengeschäft beim xxx los entdeckt
haben und ich einfach nach einer
möglichkeit gesucht habe den fernseher
abzudecken
die wohn montiert die ist von höchster
now also auch ein regionaler hersteller
und ursprünglich wollte ich gar keine
wohnwand ich wollte im prinzip nur den
fernseher haben irgendwas zum abdecken
und vielleicht ein sideboard für drunter
weil wir haben es wirklich gelernt wenn
man gesagt okay je mehr möbel man hat
umso mehr stellt man voll
jetzt wird es doch die wohnwand weil ich
dort echt
dekorativ wand und jetzt schauen wir
natürlich alle elemente hier dekoriert
das heißt farblich passend immer was
schönes reingestellt bilder eingestellt
weil ich es einfach immer schön film von
familie und von meinen freunden jeden
tag angelacht zu werden
und hier haben wir einfach die
möglichkeit die sind schrank immer
wieder individuell zu dekorieren
jetzt habe ich schöne bunte sachen drin
aber wenn ich dann doch irgendwann die
schnauze voll gehabt nehme ich einfach
alle bunten deko teile raus kann auch
was neutrales reinstellen und so kann
man wirklich individuell immer wieder
umdekorieren das finde ich schön
sie haben wir auch eine schöne deko
selbst gemacht und zwar vom wolken beton
artwork und instagram das ist der mit
dem süßen lächeln und der hat uns hier
eine lampe gemacht den nowitzki habe ich
zwar nicht getrunken aber er hat uns aus
einer schönen alten whisky flasche eine
richtig coole designer lampe gemacht der
sucht sammelt und findet irgendwelche
dinge wo du echt denkt eigentlich gehört
es auf dem müll und er macht dann sowas
genial ist raus echt cool müssen wir nur
noch anschließend das was auch an machen
können und solange benutzen wir hier das
war murat seht ihr hier einfach die
frank beleuchtung und bestreitest du
einmal den schrank sondern geht die
beleuchtung
es war moritz wunsch er will den schrank
streichen und deshalb keine hässlichen
lichtschalter nirgends apropos
lichtschalter wir haben hier im
wohnzimmer und allgemeinem ganzen haus
ziemlich viele und große fenster
wir haben überall eine beleuchtung okay
die satire das ist ja logisch aber
normalerweise hat mir dann immer so eine
riesen batterie an lichtschaltern die
man entweder beschriften muss oder die
man sich einprägen muss nach meiner
lichtschalter vielleicht noch musik
schalter weimar radio in der küche hat
dann noch was für die jalousie und da
hat man hier wirklich von oben bis unten
irgendwie 20 schalter wir haben das
ganze so gelöst mit unserem smart home
von luxor
darüber habe ich auch schon ein video
gemacht deswegen haben wir hier auch im
wohnbereich nur einen schalter und mit
dem kann ich alles steuern eigentlich
steuert sich das haus von ganz alleine
denn es weiß wann ich wie die
beleuchtung haben möchte man ich keine
beleuchtung haben möchte
wenn ich den fernseher anmacht kommt
direkt schon ein stimmungs licht das
helle licht verschwindet die jalousien
fahren abends runter und morgens wieder
hoch also alles ganz automatisch so wie
wir es eben ein programmiert haben und
hier habe ich aber trotzdem den schalter
weil sich dann doch mal mann
etwas einstellen will man muss sich
nicht ständig ans handy und muss nicht
alles über die app machen sondern kann
es auch hier machen und wir haben jetzt
unseren schalter so programmiert der hat
einfach fünf punkte in der mitte
steuerpflicht rechts oben und unten
kommt musik und links oben und unten
damit kann ich dann die jalousie steuern
also wenn ich musik wird und es nicht
vorher programmiert habe kann ich
einfach hier manuell die musik anmachen
wenn man dann auf die terrasse gehen
möchte oder einfach die frische luft
will und die tür aufmacht dann regelt
das smarthome auch dass die jalousien
hochfahren schaut man dann weiß nämlich
das haus a ha sehr die tür aufgemacht
und möchte nach draußen gehen und dann
haben wir hier einfach noch ein
insektenschutz in der mitte einfach mit
magneten
das haben wir beim rollo meister machen
lassen der kam dann hat alles
ausgemessen
man kann direkt auch schon fenster
kaufen mit integriertem insektenschutz
das haben wir leider verpasst aber so
passt wirklich supergut der obermeister
kam vorbei hat alles ausgemessen und hat
überall dann diesen insektenschutz
gemacht den man wirklich super einfach
öffnen und wieder schließen kann und so
kommen dann auch keine spinnen ins haus
oder fliegen oder wespen da bleibt alles
schön drauf was hier eigentlich elvers
karussell ist und ist normalerweise eine
relax sessel dass auch echt genial zum
buch lesen oder fernsehgucken oder
einfach zum mittagsschlaf machen
leider hab ich zeit für
mittagsschläfchen aber wenn dann will
ich es hier machen aber der stolz ist
der stuhl sessel war auch kein ja man
sieht der halt echt ein bisschen
stylische aus und passt zur petrol wand
und zum senfgelben sofa naja ich zeige
euch weiter das wohnzimmer so lange darf
jedes alpaka platz nehmen
die kiste kennt ihr noch geld hatten wir
auch in der alten wohnung schon dass sie
noch immer noch unsere becken drin wenn
wir abends auf dem sofa liegen und
kuscheln da brauche ich nämlich ionen
decke egal wie warm es draußen ist sally
hat eben eine decke egal ob 30 grad oder
nur fünf grad aber wenn ich auf dem sofa
lag ich weiß nicht warum da fange ich an
zu frieren
und dann brauche ich meine decke und die
haben wir hier drinnen dicke und dünne
und noch ein paar kissen dann hat jeder
kuschelig schön und sie haben wir uns
daran für den esstisch entschieden von
hülsta der ist jetzt drei meter lang in
unserer wohnung hat man in zwei meter
tisch der war immer ein bisschen zu
klein weil wir eben eine große familie
sind und immer viele freunde da haben
zum essen normalerweise sind wir so im
kleineren rahmen zu viert er lasse jetzt
noch auf ihrem stocke stuhl auf dem
kinderstuhl der mit wächst und murat
sitzt normalerweise hier ich sitze da
ich schaue nämlich gern in den raum
murat schaut gern aus dem fenster und
sah mir hat die sucht sich ausmalt sitzt
in mir mal nehmen wir im pub und ella
hat hier immer den platz der boss hat
die kontrolliert immer alles und die
kommt dann immer in die ganze runde ist
es bei euch eigentlich auch so habt ihr
auch im festen sitzplatz oder rotiert er
ich glaube es nicht immer so die
meistgestellte frage wer nämlich gäste
zu uns kommen sagt immer kaum freie
sitzplatzwahl
die dürfen immer sitzen wo sie wollen
auch wenn wir unter uns sind da hat
schon jeder so seinen festen sitzplatz
das gehört bei uns so so ein bisschen
auch zur routine finde ich und so zu den
gewohnheiten die die ella und die
sanierer dann noch haben und ich glaube
es gibt den so ein stück sicherheit weil
es immer wissen ich sitze da mama sitzt
immer darunter papas thema hier ja und
oma und opa oder tante ihres oder tante
nadja oder auch die eileen die sitzen
dann meist hier neben der samira
meistens auch hier neben der l adam der
papa muss dann halt ausreichen aber den
körper hammel jeden tag und deswegen
passt es dann schon was hier auch ein
ziemlich großer blickfang ist ist dieser
teppich und viele haben von euch schon
nachgefragt wo gibt's denn diesen
teppich aber bevor ich euch das sagen
möchte ich die erste mal die geschichte
zum teppich verraten
und zwar ist es ja so auf der welt gibt
es wirklich keine handgeknüpften teppich
mehr denn keiner setzt sich noch drei
bis fünf sieben jahre hin und knüpft den
teppich behandelt ist wirklich eine
uralte handwerkskunst die einfach weiter
ausgestorben ist durch die industrie und
das ist einfach auch viel zu teuer das
kann
einmal bezahlen aber es gibt auf der
welt noch ganz viele handgeknüpfte
teppiche die einfach schon jahrhunderte
alt sind und so hat ein geschäftsmann in
der türkei diesen teppich gemacht das
ist ein komplett handgeknüpften teppich
ein richtig alter und zwar macht er das
so in der türkei gibt es millionen
haushalte und jeder haushalt hat im
schnitt 5 teppiche und genug für alte
teppiche die werden dann auch von
generation zu generation weitergegeben
meine eltern die haben zum beispiel auch
noch drei oder vier handgeknüpfte
teppiche zu hause und wir als kinder
immer dachte boss und alter teppich das
sieht ja gar nicht mehr schön aus ist
schon alt der wird schon geflickt aber
mein papa hat immer gesagt der war so
teuer oder so wird wohl den darf man
nicht wegschmeißen und damals wusste ich
das einfach noch nicht zu schätzen
jetzt weiß ich wie es der geschäftsmann
hat in der türkei einfach von haus zu
haus gingen spazieren hat die teppiche
aufgekauft und hat gesagt die werden
nicht weggeschmissen
und zwar werden die teppiche eingekauft
dann werden sie geschnitten und
gereinigt eingefärbt und werden dann
zusammengesetzt das heißt man hat dann
wirklich einen kompletten vintage
teppich der eine ganz lange tradition
hat die handwerkskunst wird
aufrechterhalten und natürlich mit
nichts weggeschmissen
und hier habe ich übrigens auch den
unterschied gelernt zwischen vintage und
retro es hat mir nämlich der volkan
erklärt und zwar dachte ich eigentlich
immer retro und wintertrends gleiche ist
es aber gar nicht du kannst zum beispiel
einen retro kühlschrank kaufen der sieht
aus als wäre er von 1950 weil einfach
dieses ziel hat er ist aber ganz neu
also ist es was nach gemacht dass man
hat einfach diesen stil übernommen aber
ebene neues produkt gemacht und dann
kannst du einen vintage kühlschrank
kaufen da ist tatsächlich von 1950 also
das sind so die zwei unterschiede
und das hier ist auch wirklich ein
vintage teppich und keine retro teppich
es gibt nämlich ganz viele teppich hat
dieser sorte die sind im umlauf die
werden dann als vintage verkauft sind
aber gar nicht das sind dann viele
synthetische und ich meine man will ja
keinen synthetik teppich im wohnzimmer
haben also ein plastik teppich daher ist
wirklich aus baumwolle und aus
ziegenhaar wirklich ganz natürliche
materialien und alles zu 100 prozent mit
und vor allem hält man so die kultur und
auch die geschichte ein bisschen
aufrecht deswegen haben wir den und den
gibt es nicht nur in kunterbunt so wie
ich ihn habe da gibt es wirklich ganz
viele muster ganz viele verschiedene
farben und man kann wirklich aus allem
heraus was auswählen also da gibt es
wirklich was für jeden meine eltern
haben die teppiche
wir haben den teppich hierbei samira ist
noch ein teppich drin und die sind
wirklich richtig schön demokrat hat
übrigens den hersteller in der türkei
besucht den talker und die beiden
versuchen jetzt die teppiche nach
deutschland zu bringen denn von euch
haben wirklich schon ganz viele danach
gefragt und das ist übrigens nicht nur
ein schöner deko teppich sondern auch
ein spielteppich damit der ella spiele
ich hier wo ist die farbe grün und dann
springt sie so zu grün rüber und dann wo
es blau dann springt für
privatverbraucher können wir hier
einfach schön die farben lernen wir
haben hier ziemlich hohe decken und wir
haben ja auch eine akustikdecke gemacht
ich mein gutes gibt schönere decken
aber mich stören die löcher jetzt nicht
die akustik ist hier wirklich gut also
es hört sich nicht so heilig an
das hat man natürlich machen müssen weil
wir hier eine deckenhöhe von drei meter
fünfzig haben am rand armada an diesem
stück angebracht mit dem licht innen
drin das war mein wunsch dass wir
einfach auch schönes indirektes licht
haben und da wir hohe decken haben haben
wir gedacht machen wir eben auch hohe
türen zieht eigentlich finde ich
ziemlich cool aus denn so eine normale
tür
die wird er einfach verloren gehen und
der rat hatte die idee dass wir die
türen mit dem parkett verkleiden den
hatten wir noch übrig weil unser
obergeschoss komplett mit dem kers
parkett verlegt ist ist ein richtig
wunderschöner boden sich warm und vor
allem hat er diese schönen strukturen
hier mit dem schwalbenschwanz muster
noch mit drin
also echt schön da hatten wir was übrig
und haben praktisch den rest hierfür die
türen genommen und den kleinen anderen
rest noch für die wand in der küche und
das hat uns dann einfach eine firma
gemacht aus hockenheim der holzstab das
war der markus der war dann da hat sich
das angeguckt und hat es dann für uns
gemacht also richtig schön vor allem
sind es richtig massive türen
also ich glaube die jungs die haben die
irgendwie zu viert betragen richtig
schöne große schwere tür und die
schließen hier einfach schön mit der
wand ab und ich finde es richtig genial
als hätte man eine weiße tür genommen
wer glaube ich alles so ein bisschen zu
wenig geworden aber die parkett für dies
schon der knaller oder die ja
ursprünglich hier sitzen weil ich finde
er hat von hier einfach den besten blick
in die wohnung nach draußen und hier
nach draußen
aber mein problem und das habe ich schon
in der alten wohnung gehabt und auch
schon in der nach vornehmlich die lampe
tauben uns fehlt immer noch eine
hier oben in der galerie wenn wir hier
praktisch den bereich offen gelassen
damit so oben und unten ein bisschen
gemeinsam bleibt und nicht ganz
abgetrennt ist und damit immer auch von
oben mal nach unten rufen kann was ich
jetzt sagen das mag auch unter schauen
kann und das ist hier einfach schön
offen ist aber uns fehlt immer noch eine
galerie lampe und ich hoffe dass uns da
bald eine idee kommt denn so kann es
nicht bleiben
vielleicht hat er eine idee vielleicht
wisst ihr wo und wie ich hier oben eine
lampe befestigen kann die hier wirklich
gut kommt so kann es jetzt nicht bleiben
die nächsten jahre ich kenne das in
unserer alten wohnung fünf jahre und da
hängt immer auch das kabel hinter dieser
tür versteckt sich übrigens murats büro
hinter dieser tür das gästebad es zeige
ich euch dann noch mal separat und hier
dazwischen war eigentlich der perfekte
platz für ein klavier samira hat im
september mit dem klavierspielen
angefangen klavier kaufen ist schon so
eine sache das ist nicht ganz günstig
deswegen haben wir uns fürs mieten
entschieden denn wir noch gedacht ich
meine kinder die haben wir immer mal
eine idee wollen was machen um dann
verlieren sie den spaß dran
jetzt spielt sie schon seit mehreren
monaten spiel doch echt gut werden
trotzdem die möglichkeit klavier immer
wieder zurückzugeben falls sie
irgendwann sagt sie möchte nicht mehr
was aber sehr schade wäre jetzt im
moment sagen wir einfach eine monatliche
miete und wenn wir irgendwann sagen wir
wollen uns übernehmen dann wird einfach
die miete angerechnet wie praktische und
mit kaufen und dann kann man es einfach
kaufen
und irgendwann auf die jahre hinweg
gerechnet ist es dann auch recht gut
also ich selber kann nicht spielen aber
ich hoffe dass amira ist mir irgendwann
beibringt oder vielleicht habe ich
irgendwann zeit für klavierstunde zu
gehen so alles was ich kann ist da
natürlich muss immer zählen
ich mache das immer bezahlen
[Musik]
und damit das klavier hier nicht so ganz
alleine steht habe ich mir gedacht wer
passt hier besser dazu als beethoven
also habe ich für samira beethoven
gemalt und seid euch jetzt mal inter
werkstatt wie ich das angestellt habe
zuerst sucht ihr euch dafür jetzt ein
foto oder am besten eine zeichnung aus
dem internet aus und skizziert sie dann
auf die leinwand
ich mach beethoven jetzt auch nicht zu
groß und lasst oben noch platz für noten
und für schrift und falls euch das
freihand aufzeichnen schwer fällt dann
könnt ihr das bild auf die leinwand
projizieren oder ihr könnt auch ganz
große ausdrucken und mit hilfe des
ausdrucks dann schablonen erstellen und
die helfen euch dann beim vorzeichnen
und lasst euch dabei vorzeichnen ruhig
auch etwas mehr zeit als nächstes suche
ich mir dann die farben aus ich verwende
jetzt hier acrylfarben und ich nehme
natürlich die farben die ich auf dem
bild sehen möchte ich orientiere mich da
jetzt all unseren bunten patchwork
teppich so dass einfach ein farbenfrohes
bild entsteht und die farben trage ich
dann einzeln mit einer palette und
teilweise auch mit einem pinsel auf die
farben werden so untereinander gemischt
aber ich möchte noch einzelne und
knallige farbakzente setzen beim
hintergrund können durch auch wirklich
sehr lange zeit nehmen schaut euch das
bild auch gerne mal aus der ferne an
dritten paar schritte zurück und dann
seht ihr es auch immer richtig schön
[Musik]
als nächstes gestalte ich beethovens
anzug und der wird jetzt so ein bisschen
dunkelblau und ich verzichte ich hier
auch auf zu viele details achtet hier
einfach nur ein bisschen auf licht und
schatten und es war es im prinzip auch
schon
[Musik]
so weit kam ich jetzt beim letzten mal
ich habe das bild einfach trocknen
lassen und werde jetzt hier die
feinheiten weiter malen und ja ich gucke
jetzt einfach wie sie sich entwickelt
ich fange jetzt erstmal mit dem gesicht
da nehme ich jetzt den pinsel und eine
palette dann nehme ich einfach meine
kleinen winkel paletten einmal in
spitzen einmal vorne in rund ich habe
jetzt einfach zwei hilfe die werkstatt
zu malen und die anderen sinne der küche
und damit lässt sich die farbe wirklich
auch super dreidimensional auf streichen
und vor allem vermischen und man kann
auch einzelne gesichtskonturen machen
also diesen wirklich richtig schön
präzise ja so arbeite ich jetzt erstmal
weiter das gesicht sondern natürlich ein
bisschen heller werden aber trotzdem so
ziemlich abstrakt also kein echtes
gesicht sondern erst ein abstraktes
gesicht und die habe ich glaube da denke
ich mir irgendwas verrücktes noch auf
meist fange ich einfach irgendwie
planlos an das heißt ein bisschen gelb
und weiß
die stirn sollen heller werden und hier
auf der rechten seite mache ich die
schatten also links heller rechts
schatten und ich glaube dann entsteht so
einfach
[Musik]
und immer da wo praktisch gesichtszüge
sind habe ich ja licht und schatten das
heißt an der wange zum beispiel oder bei
der augenbraue da muss ich jetzt im
schatten reinziehen
auch bei der nase das habe ich vorher so
ein bisschen vorstrukturiert auch hier
und wenn ich da die schatten rein zidan
wird zuerst dreidimensional
[Musik]
es gibt keine bilder auf denen beethoven
lächelt das war irgendwie nachdenklich
an
ich versuche ihn nicht zu böse zu machen
ich meinen samira muss er dort klavier
spielen und das hat die ganze zu böse
auf ihre finger guckt und dann kriegt
sie angst
[Musik]
bei den haaren wähle ich jetzt etwas
wildere frisur
ich glaube das ist jetzt anmutend
geworden zwischen beethoven und einstein
gefällt mir so aber schon ganz gut
[Musik]
beim gesicht wollte ich eigentlich gar
nicht zu selbst detail gehen ist mir
damen hat doch nicht so ganz gut
gelungen und es wurde wirklich viel zu
detailliert und gerade hier bei den
augen gefällt mir das gesicht gar nicht
also habe ich es am ende dann doch
wieder weiß übermalt
[Musik]
also das gesicht einfach etwas
abstrakter gestalten und dann wirklich
nur ganz minimal gesichtszüge andeuten
[Musik]
oben habe ich noch platz gelassen für
noten und für die schrift da kommt der
notenschlüssel hin und ein paar einzelne
noten eigentlich wollte ich die fünfte
sinfonie drauf mal aber die war mir dann
doch ein bisschen zu komplex und mit den
noten kenne ich mich nicht ganz so gut
aus also war es wahrscheinlich eine
falsche komposition aber jetzt ist
zumindest meine eigene
man merkt einfach ich bin sehr
musikalisch aber ist nicht schlimm und
links schreibe ich jetzt noch das
geburts und todesjahr von beethoven auf
und dann ist das bild schon komplett ich
will mir übermalen immer gerne noch
etwas mehr zeit nehmen dieses bild ist
jetzt so an drei bis vier abenden
entstanden und ich habe immer so etwa
eine halbe stunde bis stunde gemalt und
nach dem trocknen kann es dann einfach
an die wand angebracht werden
[Musik]
so meine lieben das war es schon das war
unser wohn und esszimmer und ich hoffe
dass euch das video gefallen hat auf
instagram habe ich schon eine umfrage
gemacht welchen raum möchte die als
nächstes sehen wollte zuerst das
schlafzimmer sehen oder wollt ihr zuerst
die badezimmer sehen bestimmt gerne
einfach mal ab ich hoffe ich konnte euch
inspirieren und ein paar deko und
wohnideen geben
vielleicht habt ihr auch noch in den für
uns vor allem was die lampe betrifft
aber auch so vielleicht sagt ihr guck
mal hier oder da wär was ist anders oder
was schöner jedenfalls liebe ich mein
buntes wohnzimmer den teppich das sofa
und alles andere wir haben uns wirklich
super eingelebt es ist sehr sehr
gemütlich und ich freue mich schon
darauf euch die nächsten räume zu zeigen
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]